Welcome to English in a Minute.
If you listen to American English, you probably have heard this phrase:...
...play it by ear.
What does it mean?
Let's find out by listening to an American English conversation.
Hey, what do you want to do this weekend?
I don't know.
We could see a movie or have dinner.
Why don't we play it by ear?
Sure.
"Play it by ear" means you aren't going to make a firm plan,...
...but will decide what to do as you go along.
This idiom has a musical meaning too.
When you don't have the written music for a song,...
...but you play the notes that you think you've heard, you play it by ear.
So when you are in a situation where you make a plan as you go,...
...you're playing it by ear.
And that's English in a Minute.